[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a french action comedy film
called full speed spoilers ahead watch
out and take
care tom is a middle-aged plastic
surgeon expecting his third baby with
his wife julia the couple also has two
children the eldest leeson and soon to
be middle child no way the family is
planning to go for a two-week trip to
the countryside to get their mind off
work as they excitedly pack for the trip
someone rings the doorbell it turns out
to be tom's father ben who has invited
himself to be a part of the trip tom
doesn't mind adding his father but julia
is not fond of him ben is a clumsy man
who frequently destroys things although
his intentions are always good julia
hates his annoying habit of intruding on
private conversations she expresses her
dissatisfaction to her husband but the
couple cannot do anything to keep ben
from joining them moreover the kids love
him and want to include him in the trip
the family packs their luggage and
carries them to the car on the way they
meet their downstairs neighbor juan he
tries talking to julia but she dismisses
him quickly and continues minding her
own business he frequently hits on her
much to tom's annoyance the family then
gets into tom's brand new electronic car
called the medusa it is mostly automatic
with several advanced features that tom
isn't used to he plans to get familiar
with the features throughout the trip
before they leave noe remembers that he
left his toy harpoon in the house the
parents promised to buy him another one
at their destination but ben insists
they have to return to the apartment
anyway because he forgot to pee he and
tom go back promising to finish the
business in less than a minute ben
accidentally drops rolls of toilet paper
into the toilet as he tries to push them
down the toilet starts to flood and
overflow he ignores it and goes outside
to the kitchen tom gets the harpoon out
and attacks his father assuming he is an
intruder after calming down he gets a
call from one of his recent patients
cecilia she claims to be itchy in the
areas where she had botox tom assures
her that the symptom is normal before
hanging up abruptly they return to the
car and act as if nothing happened the
trip begins and ben immediately begins
annoying julia meanwhile tom enjoys his
father's company after an hour's drive
the kids get hungry so they stop at a
gas station to get some snacks ben meets
a blue-haired girl named melody and
befriends her melody claims that her
mother drove away with all her luggage
and she has no way to contact her ben
offers to help since they're going in
the same direction as melody's mother
but knowing julia won't allow a random
woman in the car he asks her to ride
under the seat beside him while trying
to clean the windshield he accidentally
breaks the wiper blade but keeps it
intact so he won't get in trouble they
continue the journey and ben repeatedly
suggests outrageous names for the new
kid he doesn't take the hint when asked
to stop making julia furious she accuses
him of being a pervert because he was
present at the house every time she and
tom tried to conceive a baby as they
argue the digital controller box under
the car starts to malfunction when julia
insists she wants to return home tom
presses on the break but to his
confusion it doesn't work he nervously
continues driving and figures that he
cannot change gears either after
narrowly dodging two cars on the highway
julia asks him what is wrong he tells
her about the problem but she thinks
he's only joking ben gives him unhelpful
suggestions that do not work soon the
family realizes they are in trouble
melody also starts to panic and asks ben
how long it is going to take little noe
sees her and tells his mother when she
comes to their view tom almost crashes
the car in surprise she introduces
herself while the others watch her in
horror disappointed in ben for the
hundredth time to stop the kids from
panicking julia makes them sing a song
but while they're at it they almost hit
a motorbike and erupt into screams tom
remembers that he has the car dealer's
number and makes julia call it the
dealer is in a meeting with another
family selling them the same car upon
hearing tom complain about the new model
the man simply asks him to press the
brake and declines the phone call melody
notices her mother's car driving past
them she calls her repeatedly but is
unable to get her attention suddenly she
snatches the harpoon from noe and points
it at tom she believes that the family
is kidnapping her and wants to make sure
she is safe the others try calming her
down but she hits tom and misses by an
inch ben hits her on the nose and
manages to get the harpoon back melody
finally understands that the family is
not lying tom loses control of the car
for a few seconds and hits someone
else's car's door the owner of the
damaged car is short-tempered jackie who
makes it his mission to take revenge
from the car door slamming douchebags
and pursues them at high speed then two
traffic police officers spot tom's car
running faster than it should one of
them follows their car while the other
one goes behind jackie driving just as
fast back in the vehicle ben and julia
exchange places so ben can help tom just
when he goes down to fix the brakes the
cop catches up to them and is confused
by the strange sight tom tells the cop
that their break has failed but the man
has heard the same excuse hundreds of
times julia writes sos on the back of a
map and tries to show it to the officer
but to their misfortune the paper flies
away and hits him in the face after the
officer gets rid of it the map lands on
jackie's windshield forcing him to
reluctantly stop the second police
officer catches up to him but he manages
to trick her and continues chasing after
tom in the family meanwhile the head of
traffic police is informed of the
problem but she too dismisses it
thinking that tom is lying to avoid a
speeding ticket eventually the car
reaches a crowded cross-border
checkpoint the family braces itself
hoping to cross it without crashing tom
swerves the car multiple times and
manages to avoid all the cars in their
way the head of the traffic police
finally takes the situation seriously
and orders an investigation to be held
to find out everything about the car and
its owner following them jackie also
crosses the border determined to get
paid for the car's damages tom then
sprays water onto the windshield to
clean it but the wiper blade falls off
thanks to ben he uses a cloth and
reaches out through the roof window he
almost falls off in the process but is
successful in cleaning it off at the
time of emergency tom again gets a call
from his client cecilia whose face and
lips have now swollen he makes up a
remedy before hanging up the phone he
has been driving non-stop for the past
two hours making his shoulders sore
after continuous requests ben switches
places with him and takes the wheel
back in the car showroom the dealer puts
the customer's family inside the new
model while they continue riding it he
gets a call from tom who curses him for
giving them a broken car behind the
dealer the new family also gets stuck
inside when he tries to open the door
the handle breaks proving that the car
was the problem all along the family
starts vomiting inside of it much to his
dismay in the meantime the cops find out
that tom's car was found speeding a few
nights ago they get their hands on a
picture of ben driving with a stripper
in the same car because of this the cop
deduces the family is lying and points
his gun at tom to prove their innocence
julia opens the car door and
aggressively shows them her belly after
that the traffic police order all the
cars to get off the highway that they
are approaching two officers drive in
front of the car at all times to ensure
they don't hit anything a while later
julia gets a call from their downstairs
neighbor juan who claims that their
apartment is flooded and is causing his
ceiling to leak most importantly he is
worried about all her nude paintings
that have been destroyed just when tom
takes the phone away from her juan
reveals how he has to spend time with
her again so he can paint more an
enraged tom throws the phone away and
asks his wife what the guy was talking
about it is clear that julia is having
an affair with juan she admits that it
was one year ago and she hasn't talked
to him since but it does nothing to help
tom's heartbreak but then julia also
reveals that she knows he had an affair
with his former secretary the couple
decides to talk about it later when the
children are not around to cut the
awkwardness ben says that he has to pee
immediately he is handed a plastic bag
that he uses to do his business they
then throw it out the window and it
lands straight on jackie's face still he
refuses to give up puts a bucket over
his head and continues the chase then as
a last resort tom asks ben to press on
the gas to accelerate the car to an even
higher speed the family holds hands
bracing themselves for the impact but it
never comes as the gas pedal breaks tom
curses the car dealer and throws the
pedal away in frustration it almost hits
the traffic cop and makes him crash he
survives the crash but his motorbike is
destroyed he and his partner somehow
happened to meet cecilia and borrow her
car to help the family meanwhile jackie
catches up to them and threatens them to
give him the repair money the youngest
noe uses his harpoon to hit the man and
finally get rid of him by now the news
about the car has made the television in
about half an hour they will reach a
traffic jam and are bound to crash the
police bring their car in front of the
family's car to try to stop it by force
but that doesn't work either lastly they
ask the children to be sent to them
through the window although the method
is dangerous it is their last chance of
survival the plan thankfully works and
the children are safely transferred to
the police's car when it's melody's turn
bill gets a little distracted causing
her to dangerously hang between the cars
but he quickly composes himself and she
is also safely transferred however the
other three cannot fit through the
window the traffic jam is now only five
minutes away just when they lose hope of
survival a police chopper comes to their
rescue julia is taken out through the
roof window and tied to a harness before
being taken away she tells her husband
that she loves him when faced with the
chance of never seeing each other again
the couple registers that they love each
other more than anything else in the
world speeding towards your certain
death is way more effective than couples
therapy eventually she reaches the
helicopter safely and only the father
and son are left in the car they are
seconds away from crashing when the
helicopter pulls the entire car in the
air and saves their lives but they
forget that their car is not so durable
its roof breaks sending the bottom half
to the ground fortunately for them both
tom and bill survive without an injury
all of a sudden julia's water breaks and
she has to be rushed to the hospital in
the next scene we see the family
welcoming their third child as all of
them get on the elevator to finally
return home it breaks and they are stuck
yet again
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching